Now I’m writing this before the Emmy’s
and if I had to guess they probably gave the
best drama series to Succession because rightfully
so, it’s an incredible show.
But unfortunately, if that is the case, then
that means Better Call Saul has not won best
drama series a single time.
And because of how upsetting that statement
is, I wanted to make this video and analyze
why Better Call Saul is the best show of 2023.
So the first and most important reason to
me is that Better Call Saul features an absolutely
engrossing ensemble cast of characters.
They’re all extremely deep and have intricate
dynamics.
It’s honestly really hard to pick a favorite,
but if I was held at gunpoint then I’d probably
pick Kim Wexler.
Everyone in the show I think is outstanding,
but Kim essentially excels past them and is
special to me because there’s a lot of poor
examples of female characters in media.
Kim as a character I think is a perfect example
as to how to write a strong, independent,
and fierce woman.
The writers imbue Kim with a great amount
of ferocious energy when it comes to handling
conflict that it makes her captivating to
watch.
Every time she explodes and eviscerates a
character with only her words, it’s so mesmerizing
because of how smart she is.
And this aspect about Kim doesn’t make her
a mean character or anything because she has
one of the strongest moral consciousnesses
in the show.
Her desire in wanting to make a difference
in the world and help the underdog is a wholly
endearing character trait.
She’s like a perfect storm of characteristics
that if written competently makes an excellent
character.
Which Vince Gilligan and the other writers
for Better Call Saul do so expertly.
There’s not a single moment in which I thought
Kim Wexler was written poorly or a single
line of dialogue was wasted.
And that’s kind of the case for everyone
in the show because of how immaculate and
detailed the writing is overall.
Another aspect that elevates Kim and makes
her even more fun to watch are the characters
surrounding her.
The general space for law practices and these
big corporations are predominantly male-dominated
and seeing a female character break through
and trample these characters with nothing
more than her wit and drive is extremely captivating
and inspiring.
The scene in which Kevin from Mesa Verde is
disappointed in Kim and contemplates firing
her and she actually reverses the entire dynamic
by turning the blame on Kevin was pure excellence.
The show of high confidence and willingness
to not back down against people in charge
impressed Kevin so much that he wanted to
keep working with her.
Even the scene where she successfully convinces
Lalo that Jimmy wasn’t lying about the whole
money ordeal was amazing.
Jimmy in that scene was floundering and she
actually saves Jimmy and is the one to out-persuade
Lalo.
Her pure wit, intelligence, and brass nature
is infectious and those characteristics combined
with her gender makes her a massive role model.
Like I can honestly just watch a Kim Wexler
spinoff show where she demolishes people in
court every episode.
She’s essentially the people’s champion
and another thing that is pretty refreshing
is that the writers don’t wave around the
fact that she’s a female.
They’re solely focused on creating a compelling
character because at the end of the day, whether
you’re a guy or girl you have your own set
of strengths and flaws.
And one of my favorite moments for Kim as
a character was a scene towards the end of
the show where all of her emotions essentially
boil over and she breaks down in public.
Throughout the show, she’s had such a strong
exterior and rarely showed a lot of vulnerability
emotionally.
However in this moment, since she’s essentially
dredging up the horrific past of Howard’s
demise, and she isn’t burying it alongside
Jimmy and acting like it didn’t happen,
she can’t help but break down and cry.
It’s a deeply personal and moving moment
because it’s such a convention break for
the character and if anything makes her even
more relatable and human.
Now let’s go into the relationship of Jimmy
and Kim because I honestly think this is one
of the best relationship dynamics that I’ve
ever seen.
I can’t really think of a lot that can compete
because there’s such an intriguing counterbalance
dynamic to Jimmy and Kim’s relationship.
It funnily enough is like the scales of justice
icon in which when Kim and Jimmy are together
they are at an equilibrium point for each
other.
Now this obviously isn’t a good equilibrium,
but it essentially enables Kim’s worst impulses
while also tempering Jimmy’s and keeping
him in check.
Jimmy when in the presence of Kim wants to
be the best version of himself so that she’ll
love him more.
Seeing him grapple with the conundrum of whether
or not he should tell her the truth about
what happened in the desert was heart-wrenching
because this moment could lead to their breakup.
But it in fact actually strengthened their
relationship because Jimmy told her the truth
and his core character wasn’t tarnished
by it.
Then for Kim, she has a deep-seated exposure
to criminal behavior through her mother.
The show is kind of vague as to how much this
impacted her, but it makes sense to get a
rush from doing things that are slightly out
of the law as long as they aren’t too far.
So when around Jimmy she can’t help herself
because it’s euphoric for her to execute
schemes with Jimmy that always pay off magnificently.
When together they balance each other out
to an exact morality and through their witty
expertise and newfound grey area, they’re
unstoppable.
Like them teaming up to tank Howard's character
was one of the best arcs in television and
had a wildly insane payoff that had me dying
of laughter throughout.
However, when Kim and Jimmy aren’t together
the scales shift for the better for Kim and
for the worse for Jimmy.
I love how they explore this story-wise because
when Kim leaves Jimmy she defaults to the
most stereotypical vanilla good life, while
Jimmy goes off the deep end and risks more
and more for money.
This duality is such a juicy juxtaposing relationship
that it is oddly alluring.
And because of this, it makes for an incredibly
engaging character pairing.
That and the way they left things between
Kim and Jimmy was perfect and really every
ending for each of the characters goes above
and beyond for great writing.
Shifting my focus over to Jimmy now, what
the show does for him is pretty incredible.
They make one of the most complex characters
in the Breaking Bad universe that has years
of backstory that weaves into every nanosecond
of his character’s journey.
Whether that be his complicated relationship
with Chuck, Kim anchoring him down, his criminal
past as slippin' Jimmy, his outlook on life
in which there are only wolves and sheep,
and his main goal in life being the pursuit
of riches makes a delicious hot pot combination
of a character.
To me, he’s just as interesting as Walter
White.
Now Walter’s overall all arc I think is
the magnum opus of character arcs in television
period, but I think Jimmy as a character rivals
Walter because he’s just as rich.
And I don’t mean that literally.
There’s a ton of different scenes and aspects
in which you can analyze and dive into for
his character, but to stay within season 6,
I absolutely love how the creators handled
him for the finale.
They essentially establish a character flaw
through flashbacks in which Jimmy states he
has no regrets in life.
I love how they also do this with Mike and
Walter because they really question Jimmy
about the time machine question.
Like Jimmy only wanting to go back in the
past to either make money or fix something
as silly as an injury.
But since we know Jimmy’s past through the
show, we know he’s lying to himself.
So the ending arc for Jimmy is that he wants
to redeem himself and rectify his biggest
regret in life, and that’s to make amends
with his true love Kim.
The way in which Vince Gilligan explores this
path for the finale I think is utterly brilliant.
Every scene is actually a building block element
to get to Jimmy’s redemption despite it
not being obvious.
Like the flashbacks establishing the flaw,
the present where Jimmy rolls his opposition
by getting a 7 year plea deal, which was genius
because he essentially hijacks Marie’s victimhood
testimony and throws himself into that pool
by being a victim of Walter as well, then
to him figuring out that Kim confessed about
Howard and is able to bring her to the court,
which sparks a revelation in which he can
rectify his biggest regret, to the explosive
climax of Jimmy admitting he did everything
for money to vindicate himself in the eyes
of Kim and also the law, and then the cherry
on top with him and Chuck in which we learn
that Jimmy always loved Chuck deep down.
To me this is a perfect example of not a single
wasted scene or moment, that builds to an
outstanding ending.
It’s yet another magnum opus ending within
the breaking bad universe.
It’s also pretty insane because we both
get the satisfaction of Jimmy destroying his
opposition in court by getting a 7 year plea
deal, but he also does the right thing character-wise
by burning it all down to redeem himself.
This overall tug-of-war between Jimmy’s
criminal instincts and his innocent aura of
love with Kim is one of the best complexities
a character has ever had.
It makes Jimmy a perfect candidate for the
main character of the series because there’s
always a tonne of under-the-surface motivations,
desires, and goals that makes him one of the
most intriguing characters in television.
Moving over to Mike since he’s also kind
of the second main character of the series
due to him being the protagonist of the drug
war plotline, he’s obviously amazing.
Mike has always been a fan favorite because
of his lovable and honorable personality.
Better Call Saul perfectly utilizes him and
even has some incredible arcs for him.
Even though it isn’t in season 6, his season
5 arc with Werner Ziegler was outstanding.
At first, I thought this whole development
was rather uninteresting about the whole backstory
of the creation of the underground lab, but
the second they imbue this with a heart-wrenching
conflict of Werner defecting, it becomes magnetizing.
Mike having to put him down is one of the
biggest tragedies in the show because Werner
is essentially the embodiment of innocence.
And that’s a line that Mike never wants
to cross, but he knows that he is the lesser
evil for killing Werner.
It’s one of the most gutting scenes in the
show and is emotionally wrecking because Mike
has never been this torn apart emotionally.
And the second Werner realizes his fate your
heart sinks.
He doesn’t even try to fight for his life,
and all he wanted to do was ensure the safety
of his wife.
Anytime this type of story situation happens
it’s always gutting like in Of Mice and
Men and even Old Yeller.
It’s a free ticket to make you sob, and
the way it’s executed here does so much
for Mike as a character.
Mike’s season 6 time isn’t as great since
the main focus is on Gus and Lalo, but this
season actually has one of my favorite Mike
scenes in which he meets Kim.
It’s a legendary pairing that sees the two
most hardened and witty characters have a
conversation and that alone is just so entrancing.
I wish it could have been longer, but Mike’s
observation that Kim was stronger than Jimmy
was such a gratifying moment.
I’d love to talk about Mike for hours, but
let’s move over to Nacho who I thought was
a major surprise.
Nacho as a character is fundamentally lovable
because he’s a victim who desperately wants
to escape to a better life.
Which he can do, but since his father is threatened
with death, he chooses the selfless path of
doing everything in the interest of his safety.
It creates an endearing quality for the character
in which we just want the best for Nacho.
He’s a crucial perspective within the world
of Better Call Saul because he’s at his
core an underdog.
We’re always rooting for Nacho to succeed,
but given the nature of the show in which
anyone in the game receives major consequences,
it turns Nacho’s overall story into a tragedy.
His ending like everyone in the show is flawless
and is imbued with an extremely raw and intense
performance.
Along with his entire journey up until that
point being a crazily gripping ride throughout.
Michael Mando is an excellent gem of an actor
who goes all out in every scene he’s in.
I loved him all the way back in Far Cry 3
as Vaas and I hope he can get more work in
the future.
But regardless, his rendition of Nacho will
probably always be his best work and due to
there being so many other great characters
and actors in Better Call Saul, I think he’ll
sadly be overlooked.
Especially given the amount of competition
at the Emmy’s because he didn’t even get
nominated.
Which feels like a crime, but to be fair the
competition is insane this year.
Although The White Lotus got a little too
many nominations.
So Nacho to me will always be a favorite because
of how surprisingly well-acted, written, and
emotionally investing his entire story was.
He’s essentially the beating heart that
carries the entire drug war plotline.
Then within the sphere of the drug world of
Better Call Saul, we have an amazing addition
to the Salamanca family in Lalo.
It’s pretty crazy how the Salamancas already
had so many great characters like Tuco, Hector,
the Twins, but yet, Vince Gilligan somehow
creates the most intriguing member of the
family for Better Call Saul.
Lalo is a powerful figure with high intelligence,
charisma, is cunning, patient, and my favorite
aspect about Lalo is that he offsets his ferocity
with an overwhelming presence of kindness.
It creates an unnerving presence for the character
because he gets under your skin with this
fake charade of warmth, that he then uses
to catch characters off-guard with his deadly
seriousness.
Any time he gives off this fake smile it creates
such a captivating scenario in which you are
trying to interpret what the character is
actually thinking.
It adds a lot of depth to Lalo in any given
moment because he’s a perpetual enigma.
Which in turn highlights how great both the
writing and acting are for Lalo as a character.
Any confrontation he has with an opposing
character is absolutely riveting because his
unpredictability makes him even more terrifying.
Like whenever he has conversations with Jimmy
and even Kim, you never know the direction
it’s going to go.
I’d love to go more in-depth about what
makes Lalo such a great villain, but that
would turn this already long video essay into
feature length.
He’s hands down an outstanding villain and
it’s really impressive how he was able to
break through the already magnificent roster
of iconic villains.
Although I wouldn’t say he’s the best
because I think that title definitely goes
to Gus Fring.
I really love how Better Call Saul adds a
significant amount of detail to Gus and fleshes
him out even more.
Seeing the more personal side of Gus gives
viewers more context to the iconic villain
that we didn’t get to see a lot of in Breaking
Bad.
We learn more details about his character
like his exacting and OCD-like personality
that leads to him being very observant.
The way in which this comes through the most
is how he analyzes people with his cold and
unnerving stare.
I’ll go into more about this through the
subtle and detailed acting portion of the
video because any scene with Gus constantly
oozes subtextual value for storytelling.
And that’s all done through his immaculate
performance.
He’s a character that requires an exacting
attention to detail because there are so many
intricacies that are constantly telling the
audience what he’s thinking.
He’s also arguably the smartest character
in the Breaking Bad universe, probably just
barely under Walter, but this makes his entire
story thoroughly intriguing.
His overall war with Lalo was submerged in
immense tension, and the way in which Gus
overcomes it was a stroke of brilliance.
This also makes him a better character because
in Breaking Bad he primarily loses to Walter
on multiple fronts.
But in Better Call Saul, it brings back the
mastermind aspect of Gus Fring and shows him
in his full power besting an opponent.
Thus making him even more deadly and terrifying.
Which the way he does defeat Lalo was like
a Jigsaw level galaxy brain play in which
he predicted and accounted an exact outcome
in which he could be brought down to his lab.
And every step of the way, Gus made it very
convincing that Lalo had won, when in reality,
Gus was always in control.
So Better Call Saul actually makes Gus an
even greater villain because we get to see
him overcome more conflict in his prime, while
also getting much more detailed characteristics
for the character.
Just a perfect way to handle Gus that obviously
isn’t done in any kind of nostalgia baity
way.
He serves an integral function to the story
and isn’t just here because he was a fan
favorite villain.
Which a lot of times when fan favorite characters
return in popular franchises it’s really
only done to make money, while here it actually
elevates Gus.
Now going into what I would say is my least
favorite character, we have Howard.
And that’s literally only because his competition
is so insane that by virtue he’s my least
favorite.
Which isn’t to say he’s a bad character
because he’s still fantastic and I love
him.
And if anything, the ending of Howard excels
him into a legendary status because I’d
honestly make the argument that Howard may
have the best ending in Better Call Saul.
And that isn’t just because his ending is
shocking, and instead, it’s the tragedy
of it all.
This moment in the story absolutely floors
you because you’d never assume a character
like Howard to be entangled by the cartel.
But heyyy, actions have consequences and I
think this is also a perfect way to really
punish Kim and Jimmy.
Initially, I thought there could be a possibility
of Howard killing himself in front of Jimmy
and Kim which would kind of mirror Chuck’s
suicide ending, but that was immediately swatted
away with the introduction of the candle,
which I’ll talk about later in the hidden
meaning section of the video.
Because this scene in general I think is a
complete masterclass in filmmaking and I want
to analyze it further.
But going back to Howard’s death, I think
Lalo abruptly killing him is infinitely more
tragic than a suicide ending because this
tragedy was forced onto Howard.
Right when he states that he is going to overcome
his shortcomings he dies.
He was going to become a better person and
fight the toxicity of Jimmy and Kim’s powerful
duo, but sadly that optimistic future was
ripped away from him.
That and the implications of what this does
to Howard’s character overall is even more
depressing because now all that people will
remember him as is a coke addict who killed
himself.
It yet again means that Jimmy and Kim destroys
the legacy of a character, although Kim didn’t
really have that much involvement with Chuck’s
downfall.
However, Howards is more tragic to me because
it not only tarnishes his reputation, but
he was also an innocent character who was
unfortunately at the wrong place at the wrong
time.
So in general, the creators use Howard's death
to really punctuate the terrible ways in which
Jim and Kimmy affect people.
His character kind of ascends and fulfills
a higher story purpose, and that’s something
you never would have expected to happen with
a character like Howard.
Now before going into the perfect prequel
portion of the video, I feel like it would
be a disservice to the show if I didn’t
mention Chuck.
I’m trying to base this video around the
final season of the show and why it’s the
best season of television in 2023 while also
being an overall analysis, but Chuck is inherently
an important part of Better Call Saul.
His relationship and overall feud with Jimmy
had a magnificent arc of plenty of ups and
downs throughout the 4 seasons and one of
the best moments is easily his court monologue
ranting about Jimmy.
It’s an excellent and euphoric moment of
payoff since Chuck has always held this hate
under the surface and never expressed it out
loud.
Unless it was straight to Jimmy’s face.
But finally hearing this hate pour out in
public was like popping a massive pimple and
watching all the puss pour out.
There’s a lot to be analyzed between Chuck
and Jimmy that could also span another big
video essay, but one aspect that really intrigues
me is the subjective lens in which we view
Chuck as a character.
Because in the show objectively, Chuck is
a beloved character who has done so much good
in his career, but yet, the writers only show
us the bad side of Chuck.
A spiteful, revenge fueled brother that will
never drop his prejudice against Jimmy.
Due to this subjective lens, it rallies us
behind Jimmy and shows us the true nature
of Chuck.
Were not shown the great side of all his good
deeds and most of his flashbacks generally
show him in a bad light.
And I also love how by orientation to Jimmy,
Chuck is actually the antagonist of the first
4 seasons.
Chuck causes most of the conflict that Jimmy
overcomes and it just creates such an interesting
dynamic because on paper Chuck should be a
hero.
It establishes a notion that despite how good
you are you can still have deep character
flaws and that makes Chuck feel so human.
Vince Gilligan is an utter genius for creating
such an insanely rich roster of characters
that I can honestly keep gushing about.
But there are still four other categories
that excel Better Call Saul into being the
best show of 2023.
Prequels in general can be very hard because
you can fall into the trap of creating an
uninteresting story from the audience already
knowing the ending of the main plot.
So there’s a lot of aspects you have to
account for to make a prequel just as great
as the original.
The first aspect is the choice to focus the
narrative on Jimmy.
If this was a prequel of Walter White as an
example, it wouldn’t be as investing because
we already know the set of events with Elliot
and the company Walter left.
Along with there not being much left to learn
about Walter as a character.
Through the course of Breaking Bad, the amount
of backstory we get for Saul Goodman is pretty
thin.
We understand Saul Goodman, but there’s
a lot of background context that can be added
to this character.
So in general, this show operates to fundamentally
expand and fully flesh out Jimmy as a character.
Great prequels add to the characters at hand
and any mediocre prequel that tackles pre-established
characters are never really that intriguing.
Because they lack exciting character development
and oftentimes communicate redundant information
that was already communicated in the original.
That and despite the show being called Better
Call Saul, Mike also acts as a dual lead in
the narrative because he has an entire plotline
dedicated to him.
Now I wouldn’t say that Mike needed a lot
more development character-wise because his
motivations are relatively simple and his
personality is mostly the same.
However, the main interesting question for
Mike is how he ended up working with Gus and
Jimmy.
That’s a major motivator in capturing the
audience’s interest because for a prequel
you also need to tell a story that will thoroughly
entertain the audience.
And this aspect of the story is inherently
a mystery in Breaking Bad.
What the writers came up with for these two
leads was insanely captivating while also
greatly expanding upon the world of Breaking
Bad.
Because that’s another thing that every
prequel needs to do.
If you aren’t exploring anything new and
are mostly retreading old waters, then you
are doing a disservice to the world you’re
telling your story in.
You have to introduce new elements into the
narrative that the audience don’t know the
resolution of.
Like examples being Nacho, Lalo, Howard, Chuck,
and Kim.
These are all characters that are new to us
and thus we don’t know their endings.
The only character out of this roster that
you’ll know the ending of is Lalo because
he’s obviously not in Breaking Bad and his
opponent, Gus Fring, survives their conflict.
However, the outcome of this conflict isn’t
the alluring part of the story, and instead,
it’s the way in which Gus overcomes Lalo
as a villain.
Their tug of war of conflict throughout seasons
5 and 6 was incredible and features some of
the most witty and engaging mindgames.
This is a complicated game of chess, and despite
us knowing that Gus wins that game of chess,
the way it’s played is deeply riveting.
And even though we can infer the ending of
Lalo’s character, we don’t know how he’ll
impact other characters like Jimmy and Kim.
Our only assurance is that Jimmy survives
to Breaking Bad, but the fate of Kim is in
question and that in turn makes us fear for
her safety.
Which this is something that prequels need
because, without this, it can lead to shallow
stakes from us knowing the outcome of every
part of the story.
Stakes and relative uncertainty as to where
the story is leading is what hooks the audience
and makes them want to keep watching.
Better Call Saul supplies this in every season
and essentially gets to a point in seasons
5 and 6 where it even matches the quality
of Breaking Bad.
Like the resolutions of Nacho and Howard were
sublime and these kind of moments being in
a prequel of all things is insanely impressive.
Given how hard it is to create unpredictable
plot threads in a prequel story.
Then one more aspect about Better Call Saul
is that it’s also a sequel to Breaking Bad.
So not only does it add a lot of context to
the story and characters in the past, it also
gives extended resolutions to existing characters.
Like one of the main ones being Marie Schrader.
Her testimony against Jimmy was deeply emotional
and she utterly rails into him.
It gives her character more of a satisfactory
end because she gets her justice against Jimmy.
And more than just him going to jail because
she got to confront him.
Then for Jimmy, the creators could have left
Saul Goodman’s end rather ambiguous like
Jesse’s, but it’s an inherent upgrade
than him just being in hiding for the rest
of his life.
Like sure, you can go that direction for the
story, but it makes for a stronger conclusion
to continue it and create a better payoff
for Jimmy as a character in which he gets
redemption.
The fact that Better Call Saul is able to
continue the story and create another ending
that goes above perfection is mindboggling
to me.
Vince Gilligan and his creative team are just
geniuses.
So Better Call Saul as a show is more than
just a perfect prequel, but ascends the story
foundations of prequels and does even more.
And before moving on, I find it really interesting
how they use the black-and-white style for
the present despite that generally being used
to portray the past.
To me, it kind of portrays the notion that
Jimmy’s life is in general desaturated and
lifeless and is a husk of himself.
So not only is the continued story outstanding,
but Vince Gilligan is also making interesting
creative decisions to make the story even
deeper.
For the next two topics, I’m going to combine
them since creative visual storytelling and
the hidden meaning shown through it go hand
in hand.
I feel like it’s been a while since cinematography
on this caliber always makes me question and
look into the deeper meaning of what it's
trying to convey.
Better Call Saul from the blocking of actors,
framing, lighting, scene transitions, and
more are all extremely deliberate and conveys
some kind of additive message that aids the
script.
To me this elevates the show because it makes
it significantly more engaging.
And with engaging cinematography, it makes
you an active participant who is trying to
pick up on all the small details that these
genius creators leave behind.
It’s in its rawest form the definition of
show don’t tell in which you want to engage
the audience mentally with not just words
but every frame.
Even singular or quick shots can convey so
much information that it essentially adds
an additional dimension to the storytelling.
Like let me play this one scene transition
and see if you can spot the deeper meaning
of what the creators are trying to communicate.
Now initially this may not seem like anything
major, but given the future events of the
show where Jimmy and Kim split up, I believe
this is a small nugget of foreshadowing.
It can’t be a coincidence that we hard cut
from a shot of Jimmy and Kim kissing to someone
cutting a piece of wood in half.
Which also happens to be where the two characters
used to be in frame.
Now for me personally, I knew that Kim and
Jimmy would most likely split up by the end
of the show, so this scene transition immediately
caught my attention.
Now even past the usage of creative cinematography,
the creators regularly use metaphors to convey
certain messages that makes the show even
more thought-provoking.
The biggest example is the creators putting
a lot of emphasis on the ants devouring this
ice cream cone.
For me, I interpret this as Jimmy being the
ice cream cone and the ants being the cartel.
Jimmy at this point in the story is relatively
innocent and has not yet been fully corrupted.
Or you can even interpret this past the cartel
and apply it to Jimmy’s entire later life
of only being surrounded by criminals.
His innocence as a lawyer and someone who
wants to do some amount of good has completely
melted away.
The moment that cements this metaphor is Jimmy’s
reaction to the ice cream cone and us seeing
his overall dissatisfaction.
He knows that there is no going back and his
future is going to be very grim.
Another great example is in the opening of
episode 3 of season 6 where we have this long
tracking shot that reveals a beautiful blue
flower in the desert alongside a piece of
glass.
At first, this doesn’t mean anything to
the viewer until we see the ending and find
out that this piece of glass is what Nacho
used to escape with.
So in a heartfelt way, the creators are signifying
that this gorgeous blue flower represents
Nacho.
He was the innocent flower amidst the desolate
and miserable wasteland of the drug world.
It’s a really intelligent moment that rewards
the viewer for paying attention to the details
of the show, and the second the episode ended
with that final shot, I was kind of blown
away.
And you can also interpret the storm in the
beginning as Nacho’s upcoming dark fate.
Now even going past metaphors, the creators
also use certain objects in scenes and imbue
them with a certain importance.
A subtle example that I love is the candle
announcing the arrival of Howard and Lalo.
Now the reason why I’m bringing this up
is because it’s unnatural to establish an
element like this when Howard already announces
himself via knocking.
It’s a redundant piece of information that
instead acts to establish an alternate way
of announcing the entrance of a character.
So when it inevitably comes back up again
with Lalo’s sudden entrance, you as a viewer
immediately know what’s happening.
Also, this is the part that I love, but if
you’re really paying attention to this unconventional
shot, it adds a layer of mystery and overall
dread to the scene.
Because now you’re asking yourself why did
the creators suddenly use this candle and
will it come back up again.
Meaning that there could be an additional
surprise character that shows up towards the
end of the scene.
Along with the framing of Howard’s entrance
being somewhat mysterious in which he isn’t
revealed until he’s in the apartment and
all we have is Jimmy’s reaction.
Which is partially similar to the dread-like
feeling of Lalo entering the apartment where
he emerges from the shadows.
This in contrast to the first time Lalo shows
up to the apartment is different because initially
it was meant as a sudden surprise, while here,
the creators build this uneasy atmosphere
with Howard’s meltdown and climax it with
Lalo killing him.
That and there’s so much more to analyze
just with this single scene like with the
lighting and overall color.
It’s shot in such a horror-like way of using
atmospheric lighting to establish this anxious
tone.
Along with the harsh oranges pushing Howard's
manic realization even further.
And guess what there’s even more to be analyzed
with this scene through the evolution of the
blocking, lighting, and editing.
The scene with Howard starts in which he walks
into the kitchen that is lit much brighter
and doesn’t communicate this uneasy tone
yet.
Then as the scene progresses, he positions
himself in front of this dark void in which
the living room is behind him.
Through this absence of light, it gives us
less security because of that innate feeling
of being scared of the dark.
Like hell, that’s how they brilliantly introduce
Lalo into the scene.
He starts out as this shadow creeping into
the frame behind Howard which significantly
adds to the horror.
Then for the editing, the scene first starts
with using wide shots and over the course
of it, the shots get tighter and tighter.
It progresses this feeling of claustrophobia
and essentially ends with a close-up on Howard
and the second we finally get to this shot,
we immediately know that something is off.
Because through basic escalation we know that
this closest shot is essentially the climax
and it’s framed in such a way to keep the
background behind him visible.
Like sorry if I’m overanalyzing this one
scene, but I think this illustrates the point
in which there’s an insane amount of subtext
and under the surface subtle storytelling
that is happening in almost every scene.
I’m mainly highlighting Howard’s death
scene because I think it’s a perfect combination
of everything.
Whether that be through cinematography, editing,
blocking, props, coloring, and more.
It’s invigorating as a viewer to really
sink your teeth into these scenes because
there’s so much depth to them.
Every aspect of filmmaking is operating at
such a high quality that it makes this show
a true feast.
Like Vince Gilligan isn’t just a writing
genius, but a filmmaking genius.
Through and through one of the most brilliant
scenes of a show I watched, and it isn’t
just great because it was shocking but because
of how genius the creators went about in telling
it.
Another scene that really caught my attention
that I want to point out before moving on
was the way in which they edited Jimmy and
Kim going about their lives while Mike cleaned
up the apartment.
Now I’m a sucker for amazing scene transitions
because they can really boost the cleverness
of your film or show, and the vast majority
of the time filmmakers don’t do anything
special with them.
However, here, contrasting Mike, Jimmy, and
Kim’s day with match cuts and resolves was
utterly brilliant.
Through them cutting between the coffee pouring
into a cup to squeezing out blood into a bucket,
Mike washing blood off the floor to Jimmy
soaking up the red sauce of his lunch with
bread, Kim providing evidence of a dead victim
to Mike looking at picture where Howards body
used to be, every transition in this scene
is infused with so much creativity that it
makes it incredibly thought-provoking.
This attention to detail and planning out
these scene transitions elevates the art in
my opinion.
It shows how much care the creators are putting
into this scene because this goes past just
editing.
The creators have to plan out these shots
and think about the significance of their
meaning and how it adds more to the story.
To me, it establishes a genius parallel between
these three characters of juxtaposing their
ordinary lives to the horrors of what’s
going on in their home.
It’s brilliant and so are so many other
scenes and shots within this artful show.
For the last great aspect of Better Call Saul,
I want to highlight how great the subtle acting
is throughout the show.
And how the creators use minimalist dialogue
to let the actors really shine and carry the
narrative through their performances.
I said I was going to return to Gus Fring
in this section and that’s because I think
he’s the best example for this subtle form
of acting.
His deadpan and blunt-like serious delivery
creates a shroud of mystery as to what his
intentions and motivations are.
Because of this, we have to really pay attention
to the subtle intricacies of Giancarlo’s
performance to pick up on the smallest of
details that allude to different aspects of
the story.
Like one of my favorite examples being his
talk with Hector Salamanca after the death
of Lalo.
Hector as well especially with his added context
through Better Call Saul of his feud with
Gus, really adds a deeper layer to his acting.
Every moment you can see Hector’s emotion
pour through his performance despite not being
able to deliver any lines of dialogue.
Like his reaction to hearing Lalo’s voice
and transforming his expression from being
depressed to excited was great.
But going back to his scene with Gus, I love
the subtle mind games on display here.
Gus picks up on the small detail of Hector
being partially proud and arrogant when normally
he hates Gus.
This signals to Gus that something is wrong,
which means that Lalo is most likely alive.
From here, Gus bases his entire plan around
Lalo being alive just from this one tiny little
interaction.
It’s a genius moment for Gus as a character
that makes him come across as being incredibly
observant and intelligent.
I also love the scene after Lalo’s death
in which he gets questioned by Don Eladio.
This scene is infused with palm-sweating tension
and as an audience, we eagerly watch Giancarlo’s
performance for any minor tells.
Subtle moments include Gus trying to hide
his pain when being pat down by the security
guard, Gus’ long pondering introductions
slightly portraying a nervous tone, when he
says he has no response there’s a minor
hesitant blink because he’s making a ballsy
play, then when asked as to if that’s truly
his response to the allegation he reaffirms
his stance with a more confident delivery,
as the scene progresses and Don Eladio makes
the case for Gus his stare hardens becoming
even more confident, and then this might also
be a hidden meaning aspect or me over analyzing,
but when Gus looks at hector there’s a reflection
of fire in Gus’ glasses which could portray
his fiery hatred towards Hector.
Or it could just be a coincidence.
Which again, there’s a lot to be analyzed
in so many scenes in Better Call Saul, but
going back to the subtle acting point, this
scene is thoroughly engaging because we have
to pay strict attention to Gus’ performance.
There are so many subtleties and insinuations
being made, that makes the story of this scene
so complex and intriguing.
I know scenes with reams of dialogue and monologues
are clear standouts, but these types of smaller
moments in which the dialogue falls away and
the performances take the forefront of our
attention are equally as brilliant.
That and it’s not just Gus and there’s
a plethora of moments between every character
in which the writers use minimalist dialogue
to allow the acting of these great actors
to carry the storytelling.
Like more examples are Nacho’s final scene
with Lalo where Nacho has to internalize the
oncoming doom of everyone’s death in the
compound, almost any scene in the present
with Jimmy, Kim’s boiling anger towards
Jimmy when he defects and goes against her
wishes during the Mesa Verde problem, Lalo
coldly considering Jimmy’s proposal to send
Kim to kill Gus which drastically increased
the tension, and almost every Mike scene since
his usage of dialogue is meticulous and efficient.
The acting in Better Call Saul is outstanding
and it’s unfortunate that Succession will
most likely win in every category it's nominated
in.
Our only true hope is that Rhea Seehorn wins
for best supporting actress because to me
she is the best in that category.
I know I’m titling this video as being the
best show of 2023 and that should in turn
invite a compare and contrast between Succession
and Better Call Saul, but both of these shows
are easily 10/10s.
Along with them being pretty different types
of shows.
So it’s obviously off of your personal preference
and I just wanted to make a case for why Better
Call Saul is the best show because I feel
like it deserves more praise.
It’s one of the most brilliant shows I’ve
ever seen and thank you so much for watching
this entire lengthy video essay.
I didn’t intend on it going this long, but
it would have felt like a disservice to the
show making it any shorter.
Let me know in the comments what you think
about Better Call and Saul and my socials
are linked in the description.
And again, thank you so much to my top patron
Logan Farmer.
I can’t express how thankful I am for you
hitting the highest tier.